GYNT EXPLOSIONS FROM THE
TARGETED VEHICLE INDICATED THE
PRESENCE OF A SUBSTANTIAL AMOUN
OF EXPLOSIVE MATERIAL.
WE ARE AWARE OF REPORTS OF
CIVILIAN CASUALTIES AND WE TAKE
THESE REPORTS VARIES SERIOUSLY.
WE ARE CONTINUING TO ASSESS THE
SITUATION.
>> WE TAKE EFFORTS, WE TAKES
THAT TO AVOID CIVILIAN
CASUALTIES IN EVERY SCENARIO AN
PROBABLY MORE THAN ALMOST ANY
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
I CAN SPEAK TO OR CONFIRM THE
NUMBERS OR THE BILLION
CASUALTIES IN THIS CASE.
>> SHE CAN'T COME UP WITH THE
NEW YORK TIMES IS REPORTING TEN
CIVILIANS INCLUDING SEVEN KILLE
CHILDREN WERE KILLED BY A DRONE
STRIKE IN KABUL.
THE PENTAGON ASSURES US THEY WH
THEY OF COURSE CAN'T TELL US
ANYTHING ABOUT OR IDENTIFY.
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE?
GLENN, NO ONE IN THE MEDIA SEEM
TO CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT LOOKS
LIKE TO BE ANOTHER INTELLIGENT
FAILURE.
WHY IS THAT?
>> IT IS PRETTY BIZARRE.
RIGHT FROM THE BEGINNING, THERE
WAS A HUGE QUESTION WORKING AT
LEAST FOR ME WHICH IS A MONTH
AGO, JOE BIDEN AND SHIRT
EVERYBODY THERE WAS VERY LITTLE
CHANCE THAT THE TALIBAN WOULD
OVERRUN THE AFGHAN NATIONAL
SECURITY FORCES AND WOULD TAKE
OVER THE COUNTRY.
OF COURSE THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED
FIVE WEEKS AFTER HE GAVE THE
ASSURANCE WHICH SEEMS TO SUGGES
THEY WEREN'T LYING, THEY KNOW
VERY LITTLE ABOUT WHAT WAS
HAPPENING IN A COUNTRY WE'VE
OCCUPIED FOR 20 YEARS IN
SUDDENLY WE ARE TOLD THAT THEY
WERE ABLE WITH PINPOINT
PRECISION, TWICE IN A ROW TO
IDENTIFY THE LOCATION OF TWO
DIFFERENT ISIS K PLANNERS OR
PLOTTERS OR COMMANDERS, WHICH
SEEMS VERY INCONSISTENT WITH TH
FACT THAT THEY SEEM TO HAVE NO
IDEA WHAT'S GOING ON IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THAT WOULDN'T GIVE US THE NAMES
OF WHO THESE SUPPOSEDLY
IMPORTANT PEOPLE WERE, AND THEY
JUST ASSERTED THERE WERE NO GOO
CIVILIAN CASUALTIES CASUALTIES
GREAT UNLIKE IN THE TRUMP YEARS
WHEN WE WOULD SAY IT TRUMP SAYS
THIS WITH NO EVIDENCE, TRUMP HA
FALSE CLAIMS.
ALL THEIR SKEPTICISM REPEATED
EVAPORATED OVERNIGHT IN THEY
REPEATED WE GOT OUR TARGET THER
WERE NO CIVILIAN CASUALTIES AND
THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE AND NO
QUESTIONING OF IT AT ALL.
>> THE PENTAGON, THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO RELEASE THE NAMES ARE
THE IDENTITIES OF THESE
TERRORISTS.
IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE WE ARE
GOING TO LEARN MUCH MORE ABOUT
IT THAN WE ALREADY HAVE, WATCH.
>> RIGHT NOW IS NOT THE TIME.
WE ARE STILL DEALING WITH AS WE
SAW FROM LAST NIGHTS ROCKET
ATTACKS, VERY REAL ONGOING
THREAT.
I THINK WE ARE DOING WHAT WE
BELIEVE TO BE THE PRUDENT THING
WITH THE RELEASE OF INFORMATION.
WE'RE GIVING AS MUCH AS WE CAN
AND AS CLOSE TWO REAL TIME AS W
CAN.
BUT WERE NOT ABLE TO GIVE YOU
EVERYTHING.
>> THIS IS A NEW TRICK, THEY SA
NOW IS NOT THE TIME.
NOW IS NOT THE TIME TO DEMAND
ACCOUNTABILITY, NOW IS NOT THE
TIME TO ASK QUESTIONS, NOW IS
NOT THE TIME TO GIVE US ANY
IDENTITIES, BUT THE FACT IS IT'
NEVER A GOOD TIME.
>> ONE OF THE MOST MAJOR
NATIONAL SECURITY EVENTS
OBVIOUSLY IN THE LAST DECADE OR
TWO IF NOT IN OUR LIFETIME IS
PEOPLE ASKING OPINIONS ABOUT
WHETHER WE SHOULD HAVE LEFT OR
SHOULDN'T HAVE, BUT WE ALL HAVE
THE RIGHT TO KNOW WHAT ACTUALLY
IS GOING ON, WHAT HAPPENED IN
AFGHANISTAN.
THE MEDIA DURING THE TRUMP YEAR
MADE A BIG POINT OF SHOWING THE
IMPORTANCE OF TRANSPARENCY.
THE NEW YORK POST ADOPTED A TON
THAT SAID DIES IN DARKNESS.
HERE IS THE PENTAGON
SPOKESPERSON TELLING YOU THAT
YOU HAVE TO BELIEVE THEM WHEN
THEY TELL YOU THAT THEY KILLED
IMPORTANT PEOPLE INVOLVED IN
THESE ATTACKS, BUT YOU CAN'T
KNOW WHO THESE PEOPLE ARE.
WHY NOT?
WHY CAN'T WE KNOW THAT GREAT SO
WERE JUST BEING ASKED TO ACCEPT
THEIR WORD ON BLIND FAITH, IN
EVERY TIME THIS HAPPENS WHERE
YOU KNOW YOU GO IN YOU KILL AN
ENTIRE FAMILY, YOU WIPE THEM OF
THE FACE OF THE PLANET, IT
NOBODY ASKED IF WE HAVE TO DO
THAT TO HAVE A ROTELLA TORY
STRIKE, BUT EVERY TIME THAT
HAPPENS, IT GENERATES SO MUCH
ANTI- AMERICAN SENTIMENT AROUND
THE WORLD.
WE NEED TO KNOW AT THE VERY
LEAST WHETHER IT WAS A
LEGITIMATE STRIKE OR WHETHER IT
WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS DONE FOR
BIDEN TO GET RID OF A BAD NEWS
CYCLE AND THE LACK OF INTEREST
ON THE PART OF THE MEDIA IS
AMAZING WITH THAT.
>> THAT IS A LOT OF KIDS ARE HI
I THINK WE SHOULD KNOW WHETHER
THE DRONE